哈囉 今天要分享我是怎麼養出這種水關發的
你們可能不知道我以前的頭髮不僅就是
大量沒有現在這麼多
而且我以前有一個實驗性的非常感動的沙發
每天出的我都是頂著一個毛毛糟的肌活頭
但是現在我出門
當然都會乎我
按你的頭髮為什麼看起來這麼有毛毛
而且看起來很柔順的樣子對我
這次總結了幾個非常非常重要的
一樣大的密集
首先是頭皮過裏頭皮好了我們的頭髮還蠻爛的
我從小我長被就讓我熟悉一點頭
因為他們覺得頭皮出的那種油是可以保護我們的頭髮的
但其實這種關鍵是錯的
頭皮的油只不過沒有足跡是的腥味的話
也會獨篩我們的毛腦
造成毛腦腿說讓髮是變差
而且頭髮會掉的更快
不知道大家有沒有了解過頭皮護裏油
結果我現在都是會定期的用這種頭皮護裏油
它相當於是一個頭皮的細裝油
每次用它就是蓋給我的頭皮做身體心體
所以現在頭皮是特別容易長的這種鬥鬥和小紅盛子的
所以我在找頭皮護裏的時候都非常的多一層分
很怕那個頭皮護裏會造成我的頭皮溫鬥
然後這個頭皮護裏油
我用了一段時間之後我頭皮的那麼鬥鬥真的不怎麼長
因為它原家是山茶油是可以改善我們頭皮冰冰冰的
封每次用它拿著好我的髮跟都會變得最疼
說女兒前會感覺頭皮淺鎖位有的清爽
就是終於能呼吸了頭頂這一塊的頭髮
也不見得非常非常早的順
但是這種清脆類的頭皮護裏油
我大概已經變成2.3%
第二點就是我在每次洗頭之前
我都會用這種細鍵書
從頭頂到化膳頭頭到底順便
這一點很多人都會忽視
但是其實非常非常重要
對於沙發來說頭髮毛造出的容易打擊
所以在洗頭之前碼頭髮膚開
它一方面可以重新我們頭皮的訊息管
另一方面它是可以提醒的
先把那些打擊的頭髮的書裡開
這樣在洗頭的時候就可以減少對頭髮的拉扯
導致的掉髮
然後在書我們的發燒
這一部分的時候就是要抓住這個頭髮的中間部分
再去書裡發燒
這樣就可以避免現場到我的髮跟第三點
就是我會把髮膜當作護髮素來用
因為我發現普通的護髮素
對我的這種很乾的頭髮來說
根本就沒有什麼用
我用髮膜當髮素已經幾年了
然後頭髮就是越來越健康越來越光
髮素越來越好
我用了最多的髮膜就是這
之前的你們分享了好多的紫
就是它把我的沙發給整群回來
這個髮膜可以把頭髮用成這種水光髮
然後在養光下看頭髮是這種
護光革革革的感覺
不會用過很多其他的髮膜
但是目前只有它能夠給我打到這樣的效果
最後還有一點就是洗完頭之後
一定要的即使把頭髮的吹乾
平時就頭髮會用吸水晶把頭髮包起來
是沒有什麼關係
但是如果長期讓做的話
會讓紅的頭皮的環境
又是又長頭皮會更容易吹油
完全會更容易押
再吹頭髮之前的先用一個這種
護髮油去給頭髮所以打開底
這個優可以保護頭髮就是防止
那個車風這個高溫
包我的頭髮給吹傷
包我們把水分所的處理
這個護髮油也是我
這麼多年用起來我覺得
非常非常經驗的
你它不是因為這種服務表面的油
是真的假的就是它的頭髮
能夠把這些蠟多個吃進去
然後頭髮乾的時候
也可以平時斷盟用過這種髮油
真的會讓頭髮看起來更加的
有光煮